Now before we jump in to using grooms inside of the editor,
I want us to take a quick overview look
of what grooms actually are so that we kind of understand
the underlying tech a little bit better,
as this will help us make better grooms
that fit our visual needs.
Now, when I talk about groom or the groom system,
this is a system of tools that allow you
to significantly improve the visual fidelity
of your hair simulations, and that
is accomplished by actually simulating
every individual strand of hair that you have on your head.
That is right.
You heard that correct.
When you're utilizing groom inside of Unreal Engine,
what you're actually doing is you
are importing a series of splines that
are used to then simulate hair and even fur or feathers.
We can see this example right here.
We have a head that each one of these little individual hairs
you see here are a groom, and then we also
have these feathers which act as a groom as well.
Now one thing to note that groom inside of Unreal
is utilized for displaying and optimizing as well as adjusting
materials.
If you want to do something to the hair that
involves maybe shaping it or changing it or growing it
or something like that, that's going
to be done in your external modeling
tool or your digital content creation tool, your DCC,
using something like XGen within Maya, Omnitrax, Yeti,
or shave and a haircut, or even Houdini.
So you'll use one of those DCCs
to actually generate your groom assets
and then import that into Unreal,
where you can then add physics to it
and adjust its lighting and material settings.
Now if you are, again, brand new
or you'd like to take a look at some grooms in action,
the following Unreal Engine 5 samples
all contain groom examples.
Now we have Valley of the Ancients,
which is one of the first Unreal 5 samples that
was released.
And while this was heavily using Nanite and Lumen,
it also utilizes groom on the echo character.
Taking that one step further, the sleigh animation sample
actually shows you how groom could
be used in the context of a linear animation.
In this sample, what we're doing
is we're taking the Windwalker echo character
and then making some linear content with it,
which focuses mainly on the character.
And by looking at this example, you
can see a great use of groom inside of linear content.
And again, with some more linear content,
there is the Meerkat demo, which
Weta Digital was building to investigate
how far they can push linear content, especially when
it comes to fur and feathers.
And with this example, you can really
see how far you can push fur and feathers in real time.
Last but not least, the metahumans, all metahumans
utilize grooms for their hair.
So if you open up the metahumans creator
and you take a look at their hair or their beards
or their eyelashes, all of that
is going to be done inside of groom.
Now, if you're kind of still wondering,
well, you say working in groom and your digital content
creation and coloring, bringing it over into Unreal,
what does that really mean?
Well, what we're going to be doing in our DCC
again is we're going to do our creation, our look,
and our styling.
So if we want our hair to maybe have like an updo
or we want some pieces that are flying off to the side
or we have a ponytail or some short hair,
we're going to do all of that look and styling and creation
all in our digital content creation tool,
utilizing whatever tool for hair and fur that we want.
Once we're done and we're ready,
we're going to export that as an Alembic file or a .abc
and then bring that into Unreal Engine 5.
Once inside of Unreal Engine 5, we're
going to do things like the coloring, the rendering,
and the physics of the hair, as well as
optimize it by adding level of details and things like that.
So again, when we are dealing with our groom,
we're going to be doing a majority of the creation
and the editing inside of our DCC.
But once we're done with that, all of the visual updates
will then happen in Unreal Engine 5.
So now that we know a little bit more about groom
and what it does and how it works at a very high level,
next we're going to take a look at enabling the groom
plugin so that we can actually visualize our grooms
inside of Unreal Engine 5.